there once was a woman made of moonlight  and teeth she would roam in the woods  searching for something hunting he just  kept telling me you are perfect you are  accepted all my shepherd I needed to  experience with you than I ever had  before so beautiful just like your  mother's come down on me and for me with  yourself  let us pray my wives you all came to me  broken like cruel world I took every one  of you in sacrificed my life for you I  gave you daughters sisterhood and life  that has effect on our blessing do you  think that because you haven't had your  time yet that makes you special  prepare yourself child our great  Shepherd won't be so sweet on you then  I'll be seeing you when the blood comes  to you as I went down in the valley to  pray studying about the starry crown  [Music]  first and punished  I am relying on you self of all my  children  you're the purest in your faith  [Applause]  you